carly tried to solve an equation step by
step and they tell us they see we see
how she tried to solve the equation they
say find carly's mistake so let's see
what carly did so she started with 7
times a is equal to 28.
then on the left hand side she divides
it by a
and on the right hand side she divides
by seven
well this seems strange when you're
manipulating an equation whatever you do
to one side you have to do to the other
side over here if she decides to divide
the left side by a on the right side she
should divide by a as well or if she
wants to divide the right side by 7 she
should divide the left side by 7 as well
but she's dividing both sides by two
different things so step one is where is
where she makes the mistake the right
thing for her to do or i guess maybe the
the most reasonable thing if she wants
to solve for a divide both sides by
seven then she would have been left with
just an a on the left hand side because
it had been 7a over 7 and a 4 there and
she would have said oh a must be equal
to 4. so let's let's keep going let's do
a let's do a few more of these
trent tried to solve an equation step by
step all right find trent's mistake so a
lot of mistakes happening in algebra
problems right now so g over three is
equal to four over three
and let's see the first step g over
three times three so he's multiplying
the left hand side times three and on
the right hand side he's multiplying by
one third so once again he's doing two
different things to the left and the
right hand side even though they're
supposed to do the same thing if you do
two different things the equality will
not hold anymore
notice if these two things are e if you
g over three is equal to four if you
multiply this times three and you only
multiply this times one third well then
this thing is going to become larger
because if you multiply by three that's
going to be larger if you take the same
thing and multiply it by one-third and
then the equality won't hold true
anymore in order for it to hold true if
you're gonna multiply the left by three
you have to multiply the right by three
so he made a mistake on step one
all right ling tried to solve an
equation step by step all right find
ling's mistake let's see 12 is equal to
p plus 6.2 all right
so now it looks like on the left hand
side ling adds 6.2
and on the right hand side so there was
p plus 6.2 is the old right hand side
but it looks like
they then try to subtract 6.2 so it's
the same number but over here they're
adding it and over here they're
subtracting it so they're not doing the
same thing to both sides if you want to
add 6.2 to the left-hand side you need
to add 6.2 to the right-hand side or if
you want to subtract 6.2 from the
right-hand side you have to subtract 6.2
from the left-hand side so a lot of
mistakes going on in step one let me see
if i can find one where there's not a
mistake in step one
all right alana tried to solve an
equation step by step four c equals 12
divides the left hand side by four
and then multiplies the right hand side
by four no if you're going to divide the
left hand side before you have to divide
the right hand side by 4 as well you
don't multiply by 4. so a mistake in
step 1.
let's do one more of these
all right n plus 12 is equal to 18.3
all right so over here you had n plus 12
and then rico
subtracts 12. so if you subtract 12 from
the left-hand side he needs to subtract
12 from the right-hand side and it looks
like he does that he had 18.3 and he
subtracts 12. so he subtracts 12 from
both sides
so the left hand side is now n plus 12
minus 12 was just n which is why he
subtracted 12. so you're just left with
an n on the left hand side
and on the right hand side let's see
18.3
minus twelve well eighteen minus twelve
is six
so this should be six point three so he
made a little bit of an arithmetic
mistake in step he made an arithmetic
mistake
and i think we are
all
done